in much of fashion and especially in
Footwear leather is a staple of the
Wardrobe however for both traditional
and plastic Alternatives its carbon
footprint is significant but Innovation
is making its way from the laboratory to
the runway this year two scientists
received an inventor of the Year award
for work that could vastly reduce the
waste generated from the clothes we wear
they were credited with creating
technologies that unearth Nature's
potential to put that in perspective
last year's winners were the scientists
behind the MRNA technology used in covet
vaccines Jamie wax met up with this
year's winners and the co-founders of
all birds to get the story behind a
sneaker that is brand new in more ways
than one Jamie good morning I can't tell
you have all birds on there yes all
birds I mean good morning Dana it's good
stuff just last month all birds launched
Pacers a product years in the making and
a big step towards our A Greener future
in fashion
four years ago on a quiet street in San
Francisco Albert's co-founders Tim Brown
and Joey's willinger opened this store
hoping to disrupt the fashion industry
in style and just as importantly in
substance I believe it's a zero carbon
emission wolf
from wool produced through regenerative
farming practices in New Zealand to
harnessing eucalyptus tree fibers for
its sneakers
all birds has been redefining fashion
forward what are some of the challenges
using new materials the whole industry
has had a focus on Plastics and
synthetics now for going on 50 years and
all of a sudden you're trying to bring a
new material and new supply chain into a
new product and we've been around five
years
leather is one of the most common
materials in shoes swellinger
understands why breathes it's like you
know naturally weather resistant it like
you know bends nice when you walk and it
feels good and that's a very high bar
but leather is made from cattle highs
with animal agriculture responsible for
roughly 20 percent of all greenhouse
gases and both traditional and vegan
leather alternatives are manufactured
using petrochemicals adding another
layer of toxicity and you look out into
the world of alternatives to bovine
leather and there's not a lot out there
as a certified bee Corporation fully
committed to climate-friendly business
practices all birds has had to walk the
walk on sustainability leaving any kind
of existing leather off the table until
now so how excited are you to put this
into wide use I mean super excited when
we met in November the pair gave us a
sneak peek of the all plant-based
leather alternative being used on an
exciting new sneaker line now ten months
later all birds has launched its Pacers
available in the alternative leather
called Miriam we scoured the Earth for
the best Alternatives that we could find
from this and we uncovered a group that
was innovating in our backyard
the brand synonymous with Silicon Valley
found what they were looking for in
Peoria Illinois if you can mold and
shape nutrients to make performance
materials then the whole world's
different
where seven years ago Luke haverhalls
founded natural fiber welding or nfw if
the molecule is relatively small and not
so complex haverhulls a PhD in chemistry
was researching at the U.S Naval Academy
until an epiphany brought him home to
the Midwest the most complex high
performance materials people know about
are not the synthetic ones they're
natural
and yet we make so many things out of
synthetics so why you can mold and shape
polyethylene polyurethane
polystyrene polyester effectively into
things that work for you in your in your
everyday life no one had invented the
suite of Technologies so that it would
work with the Abundant redundant diverse
natural nutrients in other words plants
nature hover Hall says is actually a
thousand times more productive than
chemicals all right this material think
of this as a dome
nfw uses the byproducts of Nature's
Bounty materials like Cork and natural
rubber yes there is all natural rubber
from trees what a lot of people will do
is they'll look at this waste and
they'll say huh how could I mix this
with plastic to get something and
natural fiber welding comes along and
says let's not use the plastic part
let's like figure out how to mix these
things things together the leather
industry no one has any of this stuff in
the case of plant leather he's got Aaron
Amstutz to thank and I just love
inventing nfw's Chief technology officer
who created Miriam four years ago this
month
it took us inside the factory where
natural materials are fed into an
industrial mixer
sheet it out and then cured under heat
and pressure how difficult is the aspect
of color okay with this a surprisingly
tough because the color isn't a thin
coating over the top the color is
integral to the recipe if I put cork
powder in the natural color will be
Brown
if I put lots of rice holes in the
natural color would be tan this happens
to be Clays and talcs they give it that
that off-white use along with sneakers
nfw is working with a host of Brands
including BMW which hopes one day to use
Miriam for car Interiors including seats
to make sure the material is viable it
runs tests for features ranging from
durability to exposure to climate Ralph
Lauren released this hoodie and fabrics
like this are produced on machines like
you see here in addition to plant
leather nfw has developed a textile line
it calls Claris which fuses natural
fibers to mimic a moisture wicking
synthetic now the fiber is in that
format that the Plastics normally can
take on and beam but it feels like top
but it yeah it doesn't feel like cotton
it is cotton you may say he's a dreamer
but he's not the only one there have
been a number of leather Alternatives
coming to the market in the last few
years Rachel cernanski covers
sustainability and fashion for Vogue
business
there's Milo from both threads there's
the ecovative material water repellent
and biodegradable there is microworks
which is partnering with Hermes so the
optimistic view is that they are doing
these small tests to see what works in
anticipation of scaling them up
it's amazing that all of this is
plant-based all of this so here's a foam
that's
no patch chemicals no plastics haverhaus
hopes to make a fully biodegradable
sneaker so when you have foam and you
have a sole you can make a nutrient shoe
that's a thing that's coming out a
little later this year when you can run
through a shredder and safely sprinkle
right back into the Earth because the
moment that any brand let alone some of
the big Brands start making nutrient
things and it's kind of like you can't
not make a nutrient thing right that's
been all Birds goal from its founding
and with Miriam and other natural
materials on the horizon they think the
sky's the limit people still for the
most part they want better products
that's our goal the way we unlock all
that value is through sustainable
innovation
the opportunity ahead of us it's like
almost infinite
how cool is that I mean this is amazing
you know you think about athletic shoes
I mean we we have kids all of us and you
are very involved in sports uh like you
think about all the athletic shoes
you've thrown away right my son alone
right and the fact that they're made of
so many components that will never ever
go away but these like we're getting to
the point where we can feel really we
can shred this and nourish a tree oh
yeah it feels great it does feel cool I
mean like and you just think about we
were talking about your dress like if
you could make a dress out of something
like that look I know yeah it's faux
leather it's spandex is it polyester so
I am not biodegradable here but you are
by underground
you can't eat it though no you you well
it's plant-based good Charlie Chaplin
down try it out babe it's a little
breakfast